thank God it's Friday
thank God it's Friday it's the day
you dare enter this [__] house
oh [__]
Friday March whatever don't matter cuz
you're slinging dick you're coming out
with a [__] torch they don't matter
they could shoot you out of a
[__] cannon and you would be
beautiful yeah I'm saying uncle Joey
here my hairdo is all [__] up but it's
Friday that's all that matters I'm mad
about hairdos don't matter about what
you're wearing
the only thing that matters is where
your balls are hanging [__] cuz it's
[__] Friday you're gonna be
prepared for every [__] scenario uncle
Joey here wishing you a happy [__]
weekend making sure you had a great week
you listened to the podcast your [__]
dick your jumping jacks you wrote your
goals because it's over it all pays off
for today that's it now it's time for
your family smoking reefer washing you
[__] it's a beer you got the world by
the balls we're smoking a little
Platinum cookies today and a little bit
of this [__] venom from perennial and
I'm saying just getting [__] ready to
rock every day I don't need no pills I
don't need this I don't need that just
two hits off the magic pipe and it's all
[__] over
it's like crystal clear you understand
me
who needs a DD pills when you got the
reefer a debt
not much going on this weekend today I
got a meeting at 4:00 I got jujitsu at
12 I got date night with the wife who's
[__] better than me I understand you
got to take care your wifey I take care
your girlfriend's making a special night
for them you know you don't want to do
it but who gives a [__] they feel good
you feel good you get your pole smoked
and that's it it's the beginning of a
new [__] day I had a great week had a
good time last night The Comedy Store
with red banning the [__] crew always
great to go down there and Saturday
night you got [__] fights I
think it's Friday Saturday Sunday who
the [__] knows I can't turn them where
there's a fight every [__] weekend
but the only thing that matters to me is
you what the [__] get doing are you
gonna put it together
who's gonna smoke your nutsack this
weekend who's gonna lick your [__]
monkey ladies I'm concerned about you
Sam so write your goals do you jump in
Josh you want inspiration BB King live
from Africa
the Allman Brothers are live from the
Beacon Theater and Lenox get it live
from Oakland 1977 Freebird when you want
inspiration how are you gonna impose
your will on these [__] Gentiles you
watch those three you understand me it's
not too thick at all it's not the tattoo
it's not how long the hair it's where
their mental status they don't give a
[__] they impose their will on you and
that's what I've been telling you
[__] listen impose your will on
these [__] after a while they
get on the [__] boat because they
know you're the real deal Holyfield but
if you don't impose your will they're
gonna look at you like a [__] mutt
L'Orange and I'm saying two feet Akama
creeping like a black cat dude the only
problem is you don't know when that
black cat showing up [__] yo Sam
so here you go and there you have you
got you [__] week setup you got two
podcast listen to I enjoyed my main man
[__] chris herren I enjoyed my man
for him I'm why don't forget to watch it
special
I'm see so you get one month for free
the cold thing is I'm raw and he's my
dog that [__] Afghani cat it's
a cool [__] and funny as [__] I
love them with all my heart man you got
to look after the young guys cuz ever at
the end they're gonna look after me man
I love all you bad [__] you
know that next week
Baltimore get the crab cakes out we're
ready to [__] go magoo beefs the
party starts Thursday night this
shipment of stars is on a mule on the
way there already and that's it and
that's that you know I'm saying the
sun's out it's snowing in Jersey it's
snowing in New York get your life
together [__] get the shovel get
the [__] reflow and get out there and
[__] shovel that's it it's beautiful
you know why cause you're alive
[__] that's right
don't taste [__] from no bit tonight but
no we got let's move into the boat what
the [__] I got confused property taxes
I woke up last and I couldn't sleep
about 2:00 in the morning I go on
Facebook some Harvey homo from around
the block is like I couldn't sleep no
more I don't think if it was the coffee
oh I couldn't sleep anymore but just my
mind is racing because I'm thinking
about the shape of the world and world
leaders but Mike you're thinking about
God you put this post on this or some
guy could come over and hug you you
[__] mutt and he's married
what is wrong with people don't listen
you want to move ahead take these
outside unnecessary thoughts that have
nothing to do you make a list of a song
to do with you and what doesn't and at
the end you'll be [__] shocked
none of this [__] godmother do it you
[__] it the bro listen
move straight ahead don't listen to the
[__] news who get the Obama but my
off listen who gives a [__] everybody's
office gets bug remember Nixon I don't
see any orders to bobbin office and we
suck it in my stupid [__] people who
gives a [__] and you write your goals
moving straight ahead I smoking some
Lisa that's what's about that that's all
you need to worry about you put the time
in you write your goals down and you
[__] commit and none of this [__]
will even come close to you don't even
bother you because you're focused on
your [__] life not what he I can't
believe it's a world powers listen if
Korea sends a missile over there going
your backyard sum up and joint and take
it like a man it's over what do you
learn do you follow me but the rest of
these [__] they got all these
outside thoughts and you wonder why you
can't get ahead eliminate that [__] and
worry about [__] you see how better
your life gets
look at that cloud of [__] death I
just busted a [__] capillary in my
brains nah man I know you bad
[__] the only one that can hold
you back is you [__] all these you know
I never see was on my I'm dissing
I can't wait to get rid of this [__]
thing get two cans with a string again
nobody bothers you mean you got two cans
with a string I'm saying sometimes I
crack myself up what are you gonna do I
love you [__] I'm a [__]
piece of [__] you guys got families you
got clean police records you've got a
job in the stock Bank or whatever
go for it [__] stop sitting there and
one of the lead from paycheck to
paycheck I was dead use your [__]
knowledge to the best of your advantage
dog get out there you're not good at
everything but you're good at something
and if you tighten up that one thing
they ain't gonna [__] stop you I
ain't good at comedy I can cut it
nothing you know I'm good at that gifted
again I'll talk you out of your [__]
pants you stupid [__] and then
work you psychologically till you tap
out I know you feel the same pain I know
you feel the same burning deep inside of
you burning you up breaking you down
breaking you out on the cold sweat but
when you lose control of your very soul
your desire takes over
you know you [__] up when you're
flopping quoting [__] Judas Priest
burning up but anyway I love your
[__] if you're going through
something right now my friends dad's in
the hospital and they told me wasn't
gonna come back and I thought about son
yesterday man at some time a bad
situation or [__] adversity puts your
mind and uh what's the word I'm looking
for man sometimes when you deal with
pain it takes you to the other fight the
next level that's the [__] kings and may
the best of [__] that turns players into
Kings bro so I've got a unfortunate
situation your life turn it into a
positive and they can't [__] stop me
understand me and that's it and that's
that I need a couple more heads I gotta
go all right
you people think I can sit out here with
you [__] in the Sun we leave
your Frenchie get an SPF number for but
I got [__] to do people to see it okay
tick tock Magoo cuz it's Friday
see you Sunday night the church what's
happening now I love you guys don't
forget get those tickets some of goobies
this is this shit's gonna sell out quick
and then I'm [__] Friday
you're gonna stop bothering me about
Joey I had me four tickets
how come I told you to east on periscope
all right but you didn't [__] pay
attention
stay black Minister every way we can
stay safe keep your eyes open or you get
I didn't get my might end up being the
hire book I see I be secret and more
Runkle of God I love you guys see you
Sunday
what the [__] is going on here huh